welcome everybody to your moment of
peace and tranquility it's families
[Applause]
families episode 5 is sponsored by
credit karma stamps policy genius and
ray khan ryan cavanaugh
take these you are not getting a dime of
any of those sponsors shout out
um you know before we get too much into
it we have a fanta by the way such a
great show today i'm excited such a
great show
teddy fresh care bears collab is coming
out this thursday at teddyfresh.com yes
i've got my teddy fresh on too this is
just a little preview my mom is wearing
a tank i should show the back looking
good yeah let me work it show it up
you're working it for sure this is the
all over
one of our one of our you know hoodies
um i'll show you our instead stand up
yes work it girl come on mom show it off
stand it up
and what what's your age again
what
don't ask him i'm about 65 why are you
acting like we haven't talked about it
before i don't need to be reminded no
i'm trying to i'm trying to just say
look how good she looks she's 65.
and yes she did just get a haircut for
those observant fans out there jesus
okay my mom has been
she's like we need to shout out the
barber we need to shout out the barber
don't forget the hairstylist asion
sassoon on wilson boulevard thank you
very much this is like the old the
biggest old lady flex in the world is
sassoon i don't know what that means i
still don't what that's what is that
soon it's the name of the salon vidal
says soon you've never heard of vidal
says only from you it's like okay i mean
who cares he cuts hair big deal
well actually he's not alive anymore but
he's
he he yeah there's a really good back
story about him but oh he did okay we
cut hair yeah and cut hair and yeah yeah
incredible
well anyways i love your haircut thank
you vidal
[Applause]
so anyway uh teddy fresh uh
uh teddyfresh.com teddyfish on instagram
here's some previews going got going on
here just to show it off a little bit
boom
uh this is the hoodie i'm wearing right
now and then here it is
oh wait there's a different piece
this is the piece in white really
beautiful too more not lipo light we got
a watch coming out
oh that's cute yeah yeah you know i need
a watch the watch that you gave me
doesn't work you wanna care bears watch
i'll hook you up
yeah you know i got your back okay here
it is look at that it's i should use it
look at this i could the arm
the care bear arm moves
with the uh hour
yeah come on that's cute get with it
thank you teddyfresh.com this thursday
at 10 a.m you have an omega ladies
constellation watch that's worth a lot
of money i think maybe we could just get
that one i've tried to get that thing
fixed three times and they can't get it
fixed it just needs a battery i think no
you need a dell sassoon of uh watchwork
i've i've changed the battery
twice okay
okay well so
mom's changed the battery twice dad
you're doubting there should be a way to
get this watch fixed your retort
yes there should yes there is mom what
do you think
i've i've brought it into the jeweler a
number of times and it worked for about
a week and then it stopped working dad
your response on the watch drama take it
back to that jeweler didn't take it back
i did mom did take it back your response
i yes i did
we have a conflict here we have reported
we have reality
okay at this point uh we have we have a
con conflict of reality
we'll have it fixed by the next podcast
[Music]
okay all right thank you uh mom and dad
for the watch updates we'll be looking
forward to that next week
okay we have a fantastic show first of
all
the drama that my parents are going to
be explaining today you want to just
give it a short intro for the people
this is regarding
go ahead and james charles is that the
one and only okay
he was recently cancelled again
yesterday on twitter and my mom is going
to explain
okay wait not right now oh just teasing
it
because there is some stuff i want to
get to first
yes
right yeah yeah
um thank you dan
and then so and then we're going to talk
about oh this is really fun i have a
porn quiz for you guys a porn quiz oh my
dad will get an a i don't know these are
really tough questions and there's a lot
of them it's really interesting
uh so i'm really excited it's gonna be a
fun show uh
here let me tell you your your bonus
slang word for the day for the hundred
dollar bonus okay i remember the word
yeats
you know you don't yeah forget it no
that's not making any no you're still
saying it wrong no i'm not i looked it
up when we went i got it it's yeats it's
spelled it's a hard e
yeats spell it's jargon and it means to
to propel something like if you're
throwing something away like can you see
like
you drink your soda pop you yeast it
into the trash can
can you spell it it's just y-e-e-t-s
there's no s it's not a yeets oh i have
a habit of putting s it's just you eat
it
okay yeah okay good that's not your word
today in the spirit of uh james charles
as we'll be talking about him your bonus
word today is spooked
spooked magoot
spooky
that it means to be you know scared
okay
that makes no but spook magooped
why the magoot that's just the way james
charles put it together okay so give me
a spook magook
uh
the child was afraid to go
she was afraid of james charles she was
afraid of change yeah the young boy was
afraid of jane of james charles yeah we
have to use lisa
okay
um
the little girl boy the little boy was
afraid to go to sleep that there were
monsters he was spooked magoot that
there were monsters underneath charles
under the bed okay james charles was
under the goats very good
okay excellent
all right so now
we have some beef to settle dad that i
saw you over the weekend
and there was the first thing you said
to me was everybody thinks i'm short
ah
and people were calling you a short king
which you know is a deer is a term of
endearment obviously re-endearing no
they mean you're short king i mean
you're listen you you are a short king
i've never considered myself short it
may be delusional but
i mean i was
close to five nine
in high school in college gravity has
ground me down a little bit i think so i
am a tiny bit shorter but i am not five
five
yeah i'm high five so if you if you look
at the tick tock people anyway people
were commenting that my dad
and i agree um you do look a little
shorter in there
i think camera angle too where but i
don't know i'm thinking here well let's
watch this back
this was obviously the infamous dance
that everybody oh my god look at how
horrible we are we we dance shredder was
this is the standout performance for me
you could have been looking from dad to
me
that was so but you do look like a short
king here dad with peace and love so do
we have a tape measure dan i think your
pants were just too big all right so so
dad let's just settle this let's get out
the tape measure take off your shoes
come on over let's get everyone here and
let's just put this to rest because
you know it's time it's time in your
life that we confront this issue and
stop lying about our height
okay well let's do it with the shoes on
no
that's cheating
you know
they say they say dad if you say you're
five nine i think that means you're five
seven no i'm not five nine now
you think so okay let's let's do a test
and also let's check chuck's mom because
your your problem was that you think
people thought that you're the same
height as mom right no my dad's
definitely taller than i am no that's
what it looked like but if i i've got my
shoes on
and and just
did you guys notice my dad's shirt by
the way the team skeet we come in peace
so my dad is putting the merch to good
use here and not paid either not a
sponsor
they should be paying you
all right
you're in contact with them right
no just once
i have not heard back from that much of
my disappointment no put them in touch i
will negotiate a deal for you to wear
that shirt i'm giving them a taste okay
all right sounds fair okay
shoot those shoes off come on well i can
just stand at the height
take the shoes off
damn these are some thick ass boots too
yeah
that's odd that i wore those today
okay so mom do you want to take your
shoes off and stand next to dad yeah
take your shoes off go away
take your shoes off woman
dad is not joking around no shoes next
to them
and obviously the vapor boy hat what is
it with this hat anytime somebody
anytime like when you turn 60 they just
hand these hats out
my dad recently started wearing
uh he is actually 70. okay so 60 70
that's when you get that well that's
true you're you're 70 and i think it's
at 70 you get the hat i've seen my good
friends leo and brad
[Applause]
okay stand up straight dad all right
all the goodies going on take the hat
off take the hat off tip down i think my
hair will be taller than the hair let's
see that take the head off we gotta see
where the dome ends
stand up straight fix my hair your hair
looks fine i have my hair stylist with
me
all right let's see
dan okay here we go make sure the top of
the hair is
no
no put your there you go
just here yeah okay we have got
five foot six inches
okay you might measure her okay you can
measure me
okay
wait in there
it's accurate yep right there that looks
good okay
and we are looking at
five foot four inches so that makes
sense right
so you're a short king there's nothing
wrong with that
and
wait what did we say
wait did you measure him at five five
dan or was it five six
okay five six six five six
oh but that's what people said they were
close they said five five
five six
he said no they weren't close
he's tall enough for me
of course there's nothing he's a short
king i love him but like i said i i've
never considered myself short yeah
because conf it's all in the state of
mind confidence he's got a big
personality you're six feet tall no one
thought he was mentally
yeah plus they died you know they
thought i guess from sitting and
my fantastic erect posture you know
thinking that i'm some big giant
muscular guy and i so i think maybe you
do stand tall you're you're like a short
king with good with big stature like tom
cruise right do you like that see that's
the short king
yeah i guess when shawn got taller than
me i should have figured out
i had diminished a little bit well let's
not
let's not forget that i was considered
like a freaking giant in our family yeah
you are the tallest one i had to fight
all the odds by being
maybe
five eleven
i thought you were six feet no give me a
break in your dream i'm not
pleased you were mom's side is all short
but on my side on the leaner side my
cousins greg and doug are tall so
over six feet so let's we i come from a
family of shorties let's be honest not
the leaner side
you guys are all short and i'm the
tallest at 5 11. my my family was pretty
tiny
my dad was only like five six my mom is
your family the one with the tiny dicks
because that's what i i
inappropriately
well somebody gave it to me
i'm just kidding 100 kidding sorry it
has to come from mom's side i'm just
kidding
okay moving right along
um so that was fun
how do you feel any different now that
you've wait you know you're five six
officially do you accept that
i'm gonna bring my own tape measure
check your tape he's still gonna be
saying he's yeah
we can do another hey haydn
maybe do it in centimeters this time
sure sounds a lot higher
um you know a lot of people requesting
from dad we have two stories i want to
touch on here
one story famous told famously told
about you dad was when we went to dodger
stadium and people would throw the beach
balls around and then you would grab
them and stab them with a knife no
yes he did do that he didn't stab people
he stopped people what do you mean now
you think it's a bloodbath that dodges
stadiums you throw that beach ball
of course he's not stabbing people he he
did he took out his his his pocket knife
yeah and i was screaming at him like
what if you stab somebody oh he grabbed
it held in his hand and [ __ ] stabbed
it now what is wrong with you he was
like doing that no he wasn't yeah he was
i was there back in the good old days oh
my god so my dad is stabbing
into the audience yeah that is that is
[ __ ]
when you could bring deadly weapons into
a stadium with you before they started
all this silly bag checking no it was
just a little swiss army knife
and you know what you could have spoken
i want to watch the baseball yeah but
there's other people you're not the only
you're not the main character right but
if you've ever seen you know innocent
beach ball yeah great innocent beach
ball until someone smacks it and oh
[ __ ]
but better that they get a knife no no
the beach balls yet dad i've been to
plenty of games nobody's spiking balls
into people's faces it's it's a whole
it's a whole thing okay so you're the
beach ball police and i hate the wave so
i just but
okay so so i'm there at the game with my
dad we'll get to the wave
i'm at the baseball game with my dad
with the whole family and it's so
[ __ ] humiliating you don't understand
how bad it feels when your dad is the
one and everybody's booing everybody's
booing you nobody's happy that you did
this for catching the balls no no people
are booing you for stabbing the ball
you're a [ __ ] narc dude that's what
the people who work at dodger stadium
dude it's their job
well sometimes people that act in the
good of the community as a whole are
ostracized you really overestimated your
people liked it it's an event yeah
people like the beach ball it's a whole
thing
it's the game it's the peanuts it's the
beach ball okay just watch at home if
you don't want to deal with the beach
balls oh your dad 73 million people
voted for trump too so what
you really
a lot of a lot of dummies i don't know
how you turned it into trump
but like basically this is traumatic and
i'm looking for an apology
well you know we're going to a game
moving the knife around like it was in a
knife fight i just calmly sat there with
it in my lap i don't care about the
knife you you you're getting my whole
family booed i'm not i'm too young for
that i can't be getting well you can't
you can't do it anymore because you're
not allowed to well i'm not there he can
do whatever he wants but i'm traumatized
by you popping beach balls at the dodger
game
well i'm sorry that your trauma level is
so low
how's that for an apology
i don't that's not a good apology
you know the other thing is like
people do the wave people have fun at
football games
everybody's literally everybody i'm not
kidding everybody in the stadium is
doing the wave but somehow in my dad's
mind
no we're doing the right we're doing the
right thing for the greater good know
everybody's doing the wave and me as a
kid i mix my dad wouldn't let any of us
do it i'm expected to sit there
and look [ __ ] angry about it and it's
so awkward too because you wanna as a
kid you wanna participate in that kind
of thing but i'm sitting there like such
a sap
it's not fun it's traumatic
the wave was a dead me this is like
therapy
you know i go there to watch the ball
game then stay at home if you want to
focus on the ball game no i go to the
game to watch things okay but you're not
the main character there's other people
enjoying themselves at the ball game
listen he's just just let dad be waiting
has nothing to do with the ball game all
it does is distract people from watching
the game
big rally going on oh let's do the wave
no one's watching the game
just my well you could watch the game
and let them do their thing that's all
oh well other people that hate the wave
okay so you're part of the gatekeeping
wave haters anonymous okay so you're
part of the true you see yourself as a
true fan of baseball hardcore i see him
standing up for
the truth you used to bring binoculars
to the game what kind of weird [ __ ] was
that
why if your seats are far
binoculars help you see you could see
fine
well now with this my dad's sitting
there with binoculars it's so
embarrassing i'm just trying to describe
how embarrassing it is going through a
baseball game we used to go them all the
time my dad's sitting there with
binoculars like what wait and i'm
listening to the radio game oh yeah he
had the game on my dad's got the game on
the radio he's holding binoculars he's
forcing my mom to take to take score
with the player no i enjoyed that
it's just too much dude
too much for we've trauma
traumatized our poor son well that's why
i only have two season tickets this year
so oh mom suggested well why don't you
ask ethan to go and i said he has no
interest in going not after all that
he's still dramatized i am still drunk
he went to yeah you wonder why i'm not
into sports it's it's just traumatic for
me
ah
i do remember too someone was smoking in
the
bleachers once which is weird that's
inappropriate and then my dad goes
he [ __ ] goes on the hunt like a damn
like uh like a hunt dog
looking for and i yelled at the person
because that was like maybe one year
after they banned smoking indoor places
yeah and it was some woman cup you know
hiding it oh no one can see it's smoke's
coming up so i just in that case you're
right politely went
you're not supposed to smoke in here 10.
she put it in a message
yeah and people clap no listen exactly
that's how you know the people clap when
you when you ruin the beach ball people
boo they're giving you signals of what
is good and what is bad you have to
listen to the signal collapse i
understand booing i'm not sure the
significance of that right
yeah and then my dad also got us killed
once at a star wars premiere oh i got
his kill you know that's almost oh at a
star wars premiere or star wars yeah you
got you know what i'm talking about the
opening of the first star wars that was
my fault
wait it was your fault what happened
digitized it whatever well we went to
see
the the star wars movie was that the
bruin and we were at
we were at the theater yeah at boone and
there were in front of us were a bunch
of young
uh students yeah
and one of them got up to go get popcorn
for the rest of them yeah and these two
big football guys
said are those seats taken
and they said yes
and he goes well nobody before the
movie's going to start yeah and he says
well you're not allowed to save seats
because we weren't allowed to we're not
saving seats these belong to someone who
just got up to the go to the concession
stand and they went and they sat in the
seat anyway and here's these young
little students and these big football
players so i tapped him on the shoulder
and i said those kids are right they're
not saving the seat it belongs to
someone who went to the concession stand
you're in their seat and he turned
around and he said to dad and i i'll see
you after the movie and your father was
so he was so terrified
i was
he had mace he had mace and as soon as
the movie was over we went out through
the side door
and i mean you couldn't even enjoy it
came back the ushers came down yeah and
they kicked the guys out and as they
were leaving they turn to me and say
we'll see you after the movie yeah
that's what happened i'm terrified i'm
prepared okay so as the movie i was i
was afraid i was i was scared i was a
young kid we went out like the back my
dad's got mace i was like what the [ __ ]
is going on here yeah i couldn't even
enjoy the movie i thought five minutes
to go yeah i said okay here's the plan
and i went to ucla so i know that area i
know where the car was see the emergency
exit back there as soon as the movie's
over we're heading back for that
exit straight to the car had the mace in
my hand if the guys came up to me i was
just gonna i had the i had the mace in
my purse
you're both armed i had the mason my
person dad said give me the mason that
you have
but you were mad at me because i tapped
the guy on the shoulder
to support those every guy dude the
girlfriend has done that rolling down
the window yeah [ __ ] you buddy and then
like yeah pull over and you get the crap
kick daddy i didn't i love women like
that i was just supporting those young
students she was right she was doing the
right thing you know my big mouth too
but they did not catch us fortunately
although oh that now that would have
been a whole another trauma watching my
dad get his ass beat they might still be
looking for me
oh man craziness so yeah my dad has
almost got his ass be in my presence
many times
but you've evaded all efforts to fight
you remember the time when we were in
the car and that guy brandished a gun
that was scary
that was
before it was uh popular to brandish
firearms was i in the car yes you were
oh my dad has almost killed me in the
car so many times i mean you really
tried to kill me that wasn't his fault
well he cut somebody off by mistake
if you don't succeed try try again
dude i mean oh my goodness like i got
cutting people off in the dude the first
time my ela hung out with my dad oh i
remember he thought he was the biggest
psychopath and dad with peace and love
you remember this right well she just
she was terrified of his driving mexico
yeah we were in mexico where my parents
lived at the time my dad is like a
pretty big suv and he's hitting corners
so [ __ ] hard the wheels are coming up
and the car is like bouncing around and
we're all so terrified that even ela who
just met you and who is a relatively shy
person and personal relationships like
that and someone who she doesn't know
she says gary slow down even my we're
all screaming at you slow down and then
ela who doesn't even know you go slow
down and you won't why don't you respond
you just you don't respond i think it's
the uh roads in mexico not my driving
stop
you were hitting those turns at like 80.
no there's no way dude you were driving
too fast we all knew it
never got a ticket you've gotten
speeding tickets before not in mexico
well
anyway
tangent that's a whole
there's a whole saga of my dad trying to
kill me and then the time he would take
the whole family in the car my dad is
like this
ucla alumni obsessed
and we've talked about that and so he
sees a guy on the road with that license
plate that says usc which is their sport
okay it's just
sports right that's all in fun it's not
all of fun listen to this story it's a
license plate that says usc my dad's
license plate says hates sc that's his
license plate he goes and [ __ ] speeds
up next to this guy and cuts him off
i don't remember that like that's hate
like he hates this person i don't know
i those were old license plates by the
way
i don't know i was a kid
oh i remember that vividly my bmw
okay flex
i actually still have those plates in
the garage the ucla alumni plates beat
sc and hsd do we still have a hate ssc
yes
that's what i'm saying he does hate do
you hate sc
no be honest dad
ah
i have an intense dislike do you see
this this man is 70 years old and still
hates a college that's how i was raised
born and raised i was raised correctly
it's amazing anyway let's move on enough
let's let's do that enough beating up
your points yeah that whole thing out
dan
it's great i like i mean i find it
fascinating
fascinating and then my oh thank you
and then um
you had an interesting story i wanted to
share too mom you got in a beef with a
bunch of old ladies you were meeting up
with like old high school friends ah
what not to do in social
interaction
you don't want to talk about it it was
pretty funny
it was my fault
it's all my fault that's a good start so
my mom start well do you want to tell
the story or should i oh my god if my
friends see this they're going to be so
pissed well your ellen hamilton
oh i just got on my high horse and
started you know why do you guys all
have straws we were we were all drinking
you know our beverages and all the girls
had straws and i started ragging on him
about having straws and then one of my
what did you say to them
that we shouldn't use straws and what
did they say
well my girlfriend debbie who is like
one of my best friends she had just
bought like 600 straws and had it sent
to the house and i just i went ballistic
and then and then um
one of our friends my mom puts her foot
down at straw oh god
i don't know one of one of our friends
is uh she's an attorney and
and uh very sweet girl this was so my
fault i just started in with um
the whole vaccination deal and she is
vaccinated but hold on tell them what
you said to them
i can't believe we're talking about this
it's so funny
this be a lesson to you oh god i'm not
going to share anything with you a
lesson come on oh what we don't have to
we can cut it if you want oh lord let's
go
let's go my my turn to be roasted
you guys want this show to work
everything's coming oh yeah yeah it
doesn't mind me being humiliated well i
just i mean i just went off on on you
know everyone should be
vaccinated and i made
i was wrong i thought that that the
government
should
uh have some sort of um
mandate that everyone need i mean if you
go into a restaurant you have to show
your card that shows that you're
vaccinated it's private
but i i kind of went a step further
further and said you know maybe the
government should just put their foot
down and say look at you know just like
during polio or you know you have to
wear a bicycle helmet or you have to put
a seat belt on it's a law my mom says
the government needs to make a law that
you have to get vaccinated to live
compulsory vaccinations
they're vaccinating you
no can't leave your house
no no i but i was wrong because that's
what they do in china i shouldn't yeah
well this is in china and i was wrong so
i apologize to my friends
even though i really think everyone
should be vaccinated i agree fully
so right but that's different from now
all my girlfriends are going to be so
mad at me forcing you to do well anyway
turn into my mom's downplay it turned to
like this big drama where everybody
where there's like an argument
everyone needs to get vaccinated and she
didn't know any of these women or hadn't
seen i hadn't seen so many years and
years complete strangers like why are
all you [ __ ] using straws i didn't
say that
good way to make good well that was the
ice cream oh that's true that was the
icebreaker you come right out the gate
with what the [ __ ] is all these straws
oh god
it's awesome all right okay enough of
all that thank you let's let's go to a
break
a short commercial break thank you to
our sponsors shout out ryan cavanaugh
who's not getting a dime
and when we come back we have a bunch of
photos
of my parents of me that we're gonna go
over and then we're gonna get on to porn
quizzes and summarizing james charles
drama so much great stuff to get to stay
tuned
credit karma has always been there to
help you make better financial decisions
and now they want to help you even more
with credit karma money spend account
you can be rewarded for good money
habits credit karma is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases
fan [ __ ] tastic
when you use your credit card money
debit card you can win daily instant
karma purchase reimburse that is such a
mouthful dude
try to say that credit card my money
debit card this is the part that gets me
you can win daily instant karma
reimburse purchase reimbursements
on items of up to five thousand dollars
let's go just pay with your debit card
and if you win you'll be notified on the
spot and your instant karma cash will be
added back to your spin account for me i
like this because not everyone can get a
credit card for various reasons and
credit cards have lots of rewards where
debit cards don't so i think this is a
great opportunity for people who can't
get credit or don't want to get a credit
card to get those spend rewards back you
know
it's hard for young people it is it's
hard out there man yeah credit card
money has already given away over three
million dollars in instant karma to over
50 000 credit karma members and counting
open your fdic insured spend account for
free there's no minimum balance
requirements no overdraft fees and free
withdrawals from a network of over 50
000 atms and
during july
up until july 23rd july 1st to july 23rd
if you make a purchase you'll be
automatically entered to win 1 million
dollars wow let's freaking go credit
karma money progress starts here and
right now visit
creditkarma.com
when money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma go to
creditkarma.com slash one money to sign
up for free and start winning instant
karma that's credit karma dot com slash
win money instant karma is sponsored by
credit karma no purchase necessary
exclusions and terms apply c rules
vacant services provided by mvp banking
incorporated members fdic max transfer
limit supply wow
you know i love stamps.com
and i'm gonna keep
using stamps.com even though the world
is going back to normal we're going out
to restaurants again we got summer plans
going to the post office no that's one
thing we don't need to return to normal
because stamps.com brings you all the
pleasures of the post office right at
your freaking home okay mail and ship
anytime from anywhere right from your
computer send letters packages pay less
a lot less with discounted rates from
usps and ups stamps.com saves businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
every freaking year dude
i mean stamps is fantastic it's like
you print it you get the postage and you
can have them pick it up it's like a
wham bam and you and it's cheaper than
the postal so much easier it's fantastic
brings you the the usps
uh the u.s postal and ups shipping
services they make it easy for small
business to mail and ship without
needing to take a trip to the post
office you can print us postage and
shipping labels 24 7 without having to
leave your desk or buy any fancy
equipment all you need is your computer
and a standard printer once your mail is
ready just schedule a pickup or drop off
it is really that simple stamps.com is
an absolute no-brainer saving nearly 1
million small business owners like you
time and money they offer deals you
can't get anywhere else like up to 40
off usps and up to 66 off ups shipping
rates come on
and with their switch and save feature
you can quickly compare carriers to find
the best rates every time that's a win
that's a win-win-win stop wasting time
going to the post office starts going to
stamps.com instead there's no risk
and with our promo code families you get
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital skill with no long-term
commitment or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
families that's stamps.com promo code
familystamps.com
never go to the post office again
policy genius are you ready for some
fireworks no not the ones popping off
outside your window until it's 2 a.m
we're talking about the fireworks you
feel when you finally get life insurance
coverage
um
you know now's a good time to you want
to get it when you're young it's cheap
when you get old that [ __ ] is pricey boy
or any type of insurance that's the
beauty of policy genius
uh policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
this is the big deal you can save fifty
percent or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius you
could save
thirteen hundred dollars or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare poli policies
uh the licensed experts at policy genius
work for you not the insurance company
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process the kind of service has
earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call whoa
that's pretty baller everyone needs
insurance
life insurance is a big deal man it is
you know you want to take care of your
loved ones when you're gone you don't
want to leave them with the whole mess
this exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes higher than options
from ladder ethos and best uh bestow
whoever they are losers
bestow bestow nothing but grief on me
when i use them
i'm all policy genius or nothing
to get started it's so easy just head to
policygenius.com
families in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and scheduling for free
policy genius never sells your
information to other companies and
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
so head on over to policygenius.com
families to get started right now that's
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
good advice
earbuds wireless bluetooth earbuds are
the game changer you need in your life
this summer you're walking you're
exercising you're out enjoying the
beautiful warm weather
earbuds bluetooth it's the game changer
you need and my advice is take the
raycons with you wherever you're going
okay a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds is gonna make all the
difference in all the fun you're doing
outside this summer you get crisp
powerful beads at half the price of
other premium auto audio brands and
raycons look great and feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors
with customizable gel tips included for
a comfortable ear and ear fit which is
everything my i got weird ear holes man
i do too it's really must have got it
from you maybe
maybe but the ear i mean the raycon's
got you covered for those weird ear
holes and raycons are built to go
wherever you go with quick and seamless
bluetooth pairing and compact charging
case
uh raycon's 24-hour battery life is kind
of epic too so
you know that you're going to get that
grind out of it boy listen up raycon's
offering 50 15 off for all of their
products for my listeners and here's
what you got to do to get it go to buy
raycon.com families there you'll get 15
off your entire raycon order it's such a
good deal you're going to want to grab a
pair
for spare
just in case they're the best that's 15
off at byraycon.com
families by raycon.com
families
welcome back everybody thanks for uh
sticking around let's do these photos
before we get into the segments here oh
i gotta see these pictures so this is
some photos that my parents grabbed
to share popular requests by popular
requests 15 years old 15. that's so
crazy you look different you look like a
different person do i
your face looks totally different well
i've got baby fat yeah you're 15 i guess
i mean i was only 15 years old
that was a year before we met
yep and there's dad dad's fame that
might dad you want to give the backstory
on this photo you seem pretty hyped on
it the black and white one with your
buddies great photo these are my
uh best childhood friends there uh fred
sweet and his brother dan sweet above
him and
my friend danny birnbaum who's in vegas
now
and what was the context the context
well we were at lake piru and i've
discussed psychedelics previously but
this was uh actually the uh
the day with my first uh
trial with uh psychedelics up at lake
pairu rule number one do it in a cool
place
and with all my friends it was an
awesome experience and then the
blonde head behind us there
wasn't really there it was an apparition
this was someone who
hung out with the manson gang for a
while she was living with charlie on the
ranch and this is was she a friend of
yours
is that why she was in the photo
she was a friend of dan's girlfriend i
think was she pretty wild
she was real quiet and
quiet everyone kind of ignored her
but it was an interesting story so this
was
i think after
manson had already been killed i'm
trying to what year was that someone
wasn't killed
i'm sorry manson had been arrested and
sent to prison oh and she was so she was
hanging out with you guys after all that
yeah oh that's [ __ ] well it's a good
thing she left and she wasn't
hanging out with her i'd be like left
the ranch well maybe she's smart enough
to leave she seemed harmless she left
her killings
yeah but she left before the killings
happened correct okay that's good so i'd
be like i'd be side eyeing her doing
acid with someone like that i'd be like
oh but anyway your look is pretty on
point very freaks and geeks look at
those glasses
big hair photo and no gray he doesn't
have any gray
massive hair that's like hillary clinton
helmet hair bro how old were you gary
look at that big neck
you keep talking about the big neck big
neck
before we met so you had to be before
20.
listen before we met
okay next one i think so that's our
wedding
uh
you look beautiful right after our
wedding dad looks like uh didn't you
look cute
he's like damn i don't know how i got
away with this one
i'm still saying that ah
i like that top mom pretty baller yeah
it was the
open button phase of uh us society you
can see my buttons are open oh my
goodness i was 16 years old here wow
look at you guys here dad's 21 and i'm
16. dude that if that happened today bro
you wouldn't oh i know
i know
21 and 16. well you know what i was more
mature than he was well i believe that i
actually do believe this
but look at her i mean she's san
francisco she just came off the cover of
dude
were you guys were you guys having uh
uh none of your
business that's my goal
did you guys you know not build a deal
she was eight yeah
almost oh you lie
that's so crazy yeah you could not do
that today i mean no that would be just
like whoa there buddy yeah we're in san
francisco we went up there to visit my
friend dan who was in that last picture
who was in dental school dental school
up there at university of san francisco
any comment on the neck dad i know you
always like to talk about the neck
big neck well that's i was in weight
training and
weighed probably
25 pounds more than i weighed this one
that was my brother's wedding dad and i
were just starting today you guys aren't
even in this photo no that was just that
why am i looking at this they're not
even in this photo
random family picture
it was just that i was well you can see
how mom powers over the rest of her
family she's not in this photo yes i am
i'm at the end she's next to her dad oh
that's this is you yeah that's the only
guy
i was really tanned i didn't even
recognize him i was really tan
yeah so mom towering over everyone else
yeah now you know how tiny my family is
wow that's my grandfather my father's
father on the end that used to speak to
me in yiddish
interesting yeah i don't think i even
see a photo of him yeah uncle it's
grandpa nathan
i always loved your
your folks were great they were just the
sweetest people my dad my my mom yeah
and that's me playing the guitar to your
sister oh wow she was like six and a
half months old i think i was 20. that
couch is such a timepiece too like
such a blast from the carpet everything
yeah that was your grandparent's house
dad looking like a
big-necked big neck the legend yeah
that's dad and there's jessica wow mommy
you look great look at you i had short
hair good haircut yeah i had short hair
and i i put blonde highlights in it damn
i used to do all my hair myself and how
old was jess in this photo oh gosh she
was young
yeah probably
theodore's age
probably wow and the next bit look at
that there's jessica again if i had a
prime this is me and my prime here yeah
you look handsome yeah not a gray hair
so i'm proud how old is jessica there
maybe
three three no i think she was like
three so this is uh
and there you are wait go scroll down
there's my baby
there you are and that's ethan popping
up from the top of the bathroom there
they stroller you're always so alert
i love that family picture look at that
look at that face that's crazy that was
like just a whole different world
lifetime
i remember that like it was yesterday
look at their eyes i remember
i went with with my sister i think and
smoked a joint before my eyes are barely
open in this picture ah leave it to you
okay look at that face family picture i
think that was your birthday you might
have been one
no you were you were sitting up so yeah
it might have been you know probably not
too yeah it could have been your first
little yes look at you got food on your
channel i look a lot like theodore when
you look at a little oh boy you so look
at look at that you look like this one
is freaking identical to theater see the
blanket i made that for you cute do you
remember that blanket no oh you
you brought that around everywhere you
went it's my cousin kathy to the right
oh i love this picture this is my
brother and me and i look so much like
theodore do you see it dan
where
where were we
theodore looks exactly like the same
green too like that same kind of smile
he does gary where where were we
at the la or san diego zoo
oh that jacket that you had on i i had
you like it was an air force jacket you
loved that jacket here's a little boy
ethan
oh
look at that face oh
look at those eyes i think theodore's
gonna look i mean i must have been like
five maybe in this photo i think
theodore's gonna look a lot like that oh
yeah look at you that was your
you were a college dorm yep we were
packing you uh dork such a skinny dork
yep that was
getting ready you look a little thinner
there but also just such a dork like
look at my posture and [ __ ]
that was coming off my hardcore gaming
days
oh look at look my my bathing beauties
my three men
dad you and sean with the glasses back
there the first vallarta trip i think
infamous for sean slicing his elbow now
look at how
burnt you were in this picture gary
we were all so drunk oh my god this is
at pee pee's restaurant in bertomayarta
shawn's looking like a boy band uh
member here
drinking age is 18 and they didn't ask
for id said and the margaritas were
strong so that was them you see how much
taller i am though it's crazy i know
yeah that was your first day of uh dad
college uh yeah i remember this moment
you guys dropped me off it was pretty
wild yeah like bye
that was hard yeah i think i cried i
cried did you i cried this is me and my
childhood dog oh spunky remember when
spunky bit your friend's butt cause i
told us damn pork chop was fat and i
remember oh what a [ __ ] hefty boy
there well pork chop he was a chunky
little [ __ ]
i don't remember them being so chunky
yeah and yeah and spunky was pretty fat
too yeah they were wow
they were anyway this is me
this is my dad
my dad my mom my brother
damn i forgot shawn used to have a
goatee that's pretty nice yeah he always
had a goatee because you couldn't grow a
mustache so that was the that looks like
vegas that's funny because i three of
you that's definitely vegas
that's funny because i got the mustache
and sean got the goatee yeah
imagine that look at look at dad's face
it's so smashed anyway yada yada and
that's that
there now you've all seen it yep
all right now from wholesome to
absolutely uh repulsive
okay before we get into the porn quiz i
feel like there's something i need to
familiar dad you should come over here
for this because i'm going to show it to
you
do you know what hentai is
hentai
oh hentai not like hint like h-e-n-t-a-i
do you know what hentai is dad form of
animation
what kind of form of animation dirty oh
wow my dad knows what hentai is that's
amazing
come on i didn't just fall off the track
okay wait here i want to show just i
feel like this is important going into
the next quiz okay define hentai okay so
i'm not gonna show this to the people
i'm just gonna show this to you guys and
you guys react here you can share the
mic with mom
so just get here just get your
this is frozen elsa frozen elsa
they're oh my god
it's frozen elsa hentai look at the
expression on her face her eyes i don't
remember that scene in the movie
[Laughter]
oh my lord
this is someone putting a straw up there
phallic
a straw up the phallic and it's a word
what's her pronouns
yeah i don't know yeah
i'll figure it out but there's a term
for the one and hentai where the chicks
have a dick right dan do you know that
or ian do you know the name of that one
there's like a specific term for it
huh so this is oh ian says he doesn't
know either oh he does yeah this is
hentai
here is what's um
this is some cartoon right dan what is
this one i'm not i'm mercifully not
looking at this album right now um this
is uh you want rick and morty okay no
way
that's rick and morty no yeah this is
from an episode of rick and morty where
mr mises runs train on
his buddies run train on uh april
he's not jewish i can see
good observation
thoughts on this oh my god
describe what you're
seeing oh my god describe this for the
people who can't see it
it looks like a
into the mic oh my god go ahead describe
that
go ahead
uh someone who is
[Music]
climaxing
to fruition here and it's a
it's a muscular
woman who has also
male genit genitalia and then there's
there's
there
the breasts and the phallus oh i didn't
see the fluid from the breast yeah where
do you see right here she's looking from
everywhere oh my god
oh my god this one is are you familiar
with mario brothers i am ah
i'll never play mario brothers again oh
and then this is kind of a classic
hentai with the tentacles for some
reason there's always tentacles involved
ew
you want to describe this one mom no i
don't
and then this is the simpsons oh lord
you want to describe that one
doggy style oh good one but what's
happening to marge
yeah literally literally the dog is
having his way with the
with a marge yes with marge
it oh this is beauty and the beast
oh lord
which really is the story let's face it
beauty and the beast is about bestiality
that's beauty and the beast always
bothered me
right well well i don't know if they
call it well they don't consummate this
he became a prince but i mean you know
he's the prince i mean that he took what
he wanted hell hell yes
all right that's hentai thank you go sit
down dad oh my god
so that ted died just to introduce you
all right well
how did how did i live without knowing
that
all right so here's the porn quiz now
i'm going to quiz you both you guys are
working together i've got the answers
and i'm going to ask the questions oh by
the way don't forget spook magoop
there's
no i know what it is what is it
it's when you're spooked and you're
you're spooked nagoot when you're hiding
some of that anime might have spooked
i definitely did wake up
okay are you guys ready for this here we
go yes question number one
what is the average age that kids start
watching porn
nowadays can we hit in can we pipe in
some like timer music dan like
like some i would say
now in the old days
they had magazines
now kids all have access to computers
so i would say 10 years old
dad i was going to say 10 also you guys
are very close you know when i guess
like 13 but the answer is 11. wow which
is pretty [ __ ] up kids that asian not
be saying hardcore pornography man
yeah yeah
you know that's if things had been like
this when i was in junior high i
probably never would have left the house
you're still in the bathroom things
haven't changed true you still don't
leave the house for that reason
question number two how many visits to
pornhub were there in the year 2019
how many visits to the website pornhub
in
2019
how many visitors to this one website
are we talking about in the whole year
individual or are we counting the same
worldwide back again
worldwide visits to pornhub
billion billion here i'll give you
multiple choice okay 100 million okay
3 billion
42 billion
i'd say 42 billion
3 billion men think about sex like every
10 seconds the answer is 42 billion yeah
can you believe that
42 i'm not surprised that surprised me i
mean wow that's a lot yeah
well if you if you if you take like you
know there's 300 million people in the
united states
yeah but people
will visit that website again and again
no i know i'm just i'm trying to
calculate how many visits is that per
person per year
and it's not like that's the only porn
site either
right no it's not like there's like team
skeet for example oh come on
they gotta start paying us
team ski con contact us
skeet me over some cash
they come in peace
eat me and skeet me some cash
okay
where in the united states
has the most searches for hentai
pornography
the south
the midwest the west coast or the east
coast who was consuming
the south the hentai pornography the
south
why do you say the south
because most people from the south are
very judgmental
they tend to be more
uh conservative and i think they're just
all wound up really tight
and i think they can't get enough of
that hentai i think so
i could be wrong dad south midwest west
coast east coast we're talking about
hentai pornography
well
you know it's probably
not the obvious answer which would be
west coast or east coast
so i'm going to go with midwest
i think
they may have more access to the
internet than people in the south have
where
you know they're still using smoke
signals and other types of
primitive communication i decided uh
it's the west it's west coast
people like dan and ian wow
and dad apparently because you know what
hentai was don't act like you didn't
watch beauty and the beast porn well
just because i can define something
doesn't mean i
am well versed in it okay this this is
funny what was the most popular search
on pornhub in north dakota north dakota
the options are student teacher
do not come challenge
country girls
make dudu
and taking horse [ __ ]
you want me to read those again we're
talking about most popular search
pornhub search in north dakota
student teacher do not come challenge
country girls makes do do
and taking horse [ __ ] i'll say the first
one
student teacher i think okay a safe bet
sir teacher sure always the second one
again a do not come challenge
i'll go with that one just to be
different from well my dad dad you truly
have your pulse
on the pornhub do not come challenge is
correct thank you
i personally would have guessed country
girls make do do
but uh hey no scat
which state has the shortest shortest
average watch time
of what aka which people people that
come the quickest i think that's what
that means
well not the people who are watching the
challenge probably
right do not come challenge
you know what this one you're never
going to guess it it's kansas the
average time is nine minutes five
seconds now i don't know how long did
that that seems like a lot like
those websites i'm in and out nine
minutes is a long is a big investment
yeah who's timing this oh they can tell
you go on the site and then they leave
and you ha what's up what they can crack
how long people are on the
on the site sure nine
minutes
i mean how much more time are you going
to spend on who's got time for all that
you can spend an hour on there i mean
it's a lot
no don't people have to work just i got
[ __ ] to do doesn't speak well of the
quality of porn they're watching i i
think you know i think that's the
opposite you got to have the plot
develop and you need the action and the
denim wall
the whole story yeah i personally
disagree if it's really good then you're
done you're in yeah get to the chase
right
okay which state has the longest watch
time that would be mississippi with an
average of eleven and a half minutes
not much different from the shortest no
not really more that's so strange okay
here this is a great one mom
what is a dirty sanchez
do you know what a dirty sandwich is
sanchez
yes what is a dirty sanchez believe i
know that is that when you take it up
the butt or something close
that's part of it i i'll give howard
stern credit for me knowing this dad
would you like to define what a dirty
sanchez is i think it's uh
receiving oral favors while sitting on
the toilet that's that'd be awesome
pumpkin that's a bumpkin yes
see there is a name for that also
okay dirty sanchez do you want to take a
guess you just well i did i well so
that's part of it it's when you
uh rub
after that act you rub your member
over your partner's lip thereby giving
them a mustache
that's ronnie's specialty
that's gross it's pretty gross man some
people are really sick you think
dirty sanchez
uh next up what is edging ugh i don't
know why we have to do this one edging
edging yeah i
can't your grass is growing over the
sidewalk and you've got it let's skip
edging let's skip it yeah maybe we
should
okay this is a weird one i didn't know
about this one
okay what is morning wood not morning
like when the sun comes up but morning
like m-o-u-r-n
when you're in mourning what is morning
wood a play on the classic
morning wood
is it when you wake up with a boner
the sexual pleasure one feels when using
a powerful tool
such as an axe or chopping wood
the sadness one feels due to the loss of
a boner or
when one pops a boner at a funeral or
wake
i'd say the last yeah this is a weird
one guys where did this one come from
morning wood when you're in morning is
that is that
does that excite people to be morning i
don't know oh man it's like a weird
thing
the human race is really you're taking
our heads and crashers
it's like we're gonna go to funerals and
not meet women instead of
weddings
right that was actually a plot point in
wedding crashers
but i think we could do a spin-off of
wedding crashers called morning wood
where they go pick up chicks at funerals
i'd watch that aka funeral crashers yeah
no we'll call it morning wood all right
next week thanks stay tuned
what okay sick
sick sick sick
okay well what is
this is a new one for me what is a
twitter bang
a twitter i'm just gonna define it yeah
i don't have i've never heard
it's when you have sex with someone whom
you've exchanged less than 140 words
with
a twitter bank
wow
that's very specific
it should be characters not words sorry
i think it was misdefined by someone
yeah characters
no i don't like that one
okay now this is a speed run so i'm
going to hit you with a bunch of fast
ones this is sex is this
sex slang or old english
so i'm going to give you an example of
one okay i'll give you one now just to
get you guys warmed up okay so this is
going to be fast and furious
and you have to tell me sex slang or old
english so the first one here this is
just a test
the do beater
the do beater
sex slang or old english
do beater i would say old english oh you
guys are right it means an especially
large shoe and
and consequently a clumsy or awkward
person a dew beater
okay ready guys ready all right here we
go
a sasquatch sasquatch
old english or sex slang sex slang
i would agree sex sling sex slang is
correct when an unkempt pubes begins to
grow down your thighs
what is that of a word for that sat
sashkaraj
like a sasquatch sesh scratch that's a
good play on words
begin to grow down your thighs
okay ready a bareback bareback
old english or sex
back
slang
sex
not wearing a condom
or biting a horse without a saddle in
old english you guys got that one right
dribble drink driggle drink
english old english man you guys are on
fire you haven't missed yet an untidy
woman a drink drink oh i'm have to
remember angle drink driggle trickle
jingle
all right here we go
dribble jingle
am i it's jiggle jingle i mean it's
close enough you're adding a few
consonants dribble
drink dr dreigle raggle draggle jiggle
draggle dribble drag jiggle dragon what
is that like uh like uh someone unkept
like a i mean i i hate that
[ __ ] back in the day
yeah opposite of your mother we should
bring that back
that's a fun word to say bit jiggle
dragon
all right up next
jelking
jelking
sex
sex word i'm gonna go with old english
okay we have a split decision do you
guys want to come to an agreement here
on jelqing how do you spell [ __ ]
how do i spell [ __ ] it's a joke okay
never mind it's a joke
joking
the fans will get it it is a whatever
sexling
thank you it mean this is weird you guys
i'm sorry about this the practice of of
stroking the penis when erect in a
particular way to increase its size
i don't [ __ ] know what's the
difference between that and regular
isn't that the whole
point says this is a symphony oh i think
i know what that means it's a similar
concept to using a penis pump i think
this means when you like pull it
that that must mean what joking is i've
got the demonstration help
interesting okay joking all right here
we go pegging pegging old english or
uh
sex act i'd say old english sex dad
knows what pegging is
he's been around he's been around too
long
dad go ahead and define packing i know
you know what that is
i don't remember exactly and i'm not
playing naive here but i know it is it's
when some it's one of i think
specifically i i could it's when a woman
straps on and does the deed on the back
okay
yes oh that pegging yeah okay right
yes
all right okay here we go a jilly wet
foot a jelly wet foot that's got to be
old english
i would agree
final answer
you're right i wish julie wetfoot was a
porn act
what is what is it yeah it's a swindling
businessman the old jilly wetfoot
and finally we have
sploshing splashing
sploshing that sounds like a sex term
i'm going to agree
splashing you guys are corrected is a
sex term a sexual fetish that entails
bringing food into your sex life i'll uh
george cassandra eating a sandwich
especially large quantities of food so
that things get messy sploshing
man you guys nailed that uh you guys
like literally
really good thank you i destroyed that
congratulations man
[Applause]
what an accomplishment
didn't make a hundred dollars though
donna get with the pro
i didn't
what's the word again spoop spook with
you spooked
spook
spooked
spooked
that whole segment spooked
me
i mean that was proper but i think we
need a more spontaneous usage
can we discuss the word
shoddy
oh show you shouty yeah you want me
shouty oh my god
uh
critics of your pronunciation said it
perfectly fine shouty
yes many people saying you have no right
to tell your parents how to pronounce it
when you're you say it
like shouting i'm obviously
overpronouncing it for a comedic value
here guys okay but my dad is shouty it's
my shout out your dad's right though
that uh or is it shouty like she's like
like he's my shouty he's my other half
shah youtube
literally like 80 percent of the
comments were calling you no i saw them
i don't know gary can you be her shady
go shouty it's your birthday we going to
party right now it's your birthday we're
going to drink picadilly well he is your
birthday okay
that was to follow up on my
silo
it's okay you got to give it a little
bit i still think it's shouty because
you're saying shorty shorty shouty
shoddy shoddy hey we don't make this up
i'm just we're just reporting
so oh so we're gonna do james charles
but my mom as i was going to the
bathroom grabbed yes i'm freezing throw
this off though it's so beautiful it
looks great
wow that is
uh it's the uh
sweater
mole hair
super plush super beautiful premium
workout
is that available because everyone wants
what mom wears and i think they will be
available on thursdays
awesome yeah i think i love it it's
beautiful
all right so mom i believe you have
james charles notes so you know james
charles the topic we've talked a lot
about but recently he was in trending on
twitter again my mom is here to explain
why how many pages of notes do you have
today well you know this was this was
actually notes from other things i don't
think i put can i take a no no no this
was about my butterflies so mom um
would you like to change this yeah
oh boy okay
here's the deal okay i sound like
president biden here's the deal folks
there are
17 year olds and then there are 17 year
olds and there's 22 year olds and
there's 22 year olds which reminds me of
a story
when your brother
was
celebrating his bar mitzvah at 13
they had balloons and they
that were filled with helium
and the kids went around popping the
balloons and inhaling the helium
and
i went to a bar mitzvah of your cousin
adams
and the boys
were dancing with the girls and in fact
they had roaming hands
so some kids
you know are more mature than others
being that was more mature
well they were the same age but like
you know adam's friends from the city
were like they were interested you
thought they had grown up a little
faster yeah they were a little faster
okay
okay okay all right well
that being said i think i don't like
where this is going i think this james
charles yeah is very immature
okay
he's very immature i think that most
guys i don't want to
generalize but a lot of guys at the age
of 22 are very immature yeah oh yeah for
sure okay
and um
one thing that you need to know james if
you're
paying that if you're if you're paying
it he is he's watching he was over for
dinner last night okay he's listening
the thing is
there is a legal age
and you can't be under 18. wait hold on
we just got done talking about how dad
when as 21 year old well that's why when
you're 16. that's why i said there are
17 year olds and their mom said that
okay the point is
17 to 22 it's only five years okay
the point of the matter is
you went to jail already you got in
trouble whoa whoa whoa james didn't go i
thought he went i thought he went to
jail oh okay i'm glad i'm familiar with
this one james has never been to jail he
never went to prison he should have been
yeah he could have oh okay for some
reason i thought i
thought i read that he had
served time or something because of it
she probably saw all of her uh
thumbnails on the podcast
i think you're confusing is that he's
gotten in trouble for doing this before
he has gotten jeans or something okay
he's like
youtube you uh youtube like demonetized
them for a minute okay right i think
that happened
well i love that they're like oh you
you're flir you're trying to hook up
with young boys we'll demonetize you for
two weeks right
i just think
he's got a career
he's fortunate enough at this young age
to be financially successful and have a
following that he has
and for him
to be so careless
you know is is foolish for one
and then
um
[Music]
i think that
you know if he i understand someone like
him he wants to meet someone and and
it's very hard for someone who maybe is
you know well known
he can't exactly go to you know
you know i mean there are different
websites but obviously you have to be
anonymous
you know being that if he comes out and
says oh i'm james celebrities yeah oh
there are yeah
okay it's me ben affleck why did you
unfriend me
well i mean i
okay i don't understand why he's not
attracted to guys maybe that are older
here's the problem with james charles
too
he got in trouble for this before right
and he said i'm not gonna do this
anymore and then he got in trouble for
it again right so it's almost like he
can't help himself going after the
younger guys well there's no
consequences there's no major
consequences and when you watch
his his video about
you know his mia culpa oh i'm going to
apologize and explain the whole thing
what's his motivation
um i'm lonely i'm desperate to meet
someone so desperation is excused for
constantly going after
underage
uh boys and it just happens over and
over again i think
he has a deep-seated desire to be caught
and face some consequences really as
kind of a way to
cure himself perhaps you think he wants
to get crying
he's doing he's so brave obvious things
it's so brazen like the thing with
pink i think he i think people like that
can feel privileged and so that they
don't face consequences but
you know he's just immature
and he maybe he feels more comfortable
with a younger boy opposed to an older
man because he doesn't feel secure
enough
to go with a guy that's 23. yeah you
can't excuse predatory he's continually
said that
he prefers younger men
he likes to date men who look as young
as possible who are legal he said that
on his right but the problem is and also
how do you feel about the fact that he's
tapping his audience
young boys some of them were as young as
like how how young were they
i don't want to speak at a term but i
thought it was just 7 13
oh god see now that now if there was a
13 year old in there
14 15. i thought it was for sure sure
there was one 15. let's say 15. but did
he know he was 15. he says he didn't but
he doesn't do his due diligence to check
he's right that's another well this one
young man purple i mean i saw you when
you were
15. it's pretty obvious when someone's
15 or 21 right it's a huge difference
yeah so what's the deal with purple
because this is what he got canceled for
something about this gamer purple and
i'm not sure he's 17 years old he used
to be called pool boy three at one time
and i think he changed his
his name but you know what does purple
do who is he he he he does uh he's known
for playing gamer games okay i think
what what was the game that he'd like to
know wait let me see yeah
uh
let's see if we have it written down
he's he's known for a particular game oh
yeah i do have it is it pong
he's well known for streaming minecraft
oh there you go nailed it on his twitch
channel nailed it and he said and his
bio states that he's 17 years old so so
what's the problem the problem is james
knock it off
what did he do i don't know what he did
well he he just liked him he he went on
his there was a picture that someone
posted of him
with the uh email or text message he had
sent he's very suggestive and just
you know
i don't think it was suggestive the
thing that i read just saying that he
liked him and one of the other uh can i
pull out i gotta pull this up to see
because i am doubting your guys's uh
reporting on this one
okay so here's an article that that
details exactly what happened so this is
from newsweek they say james charles is
facing another bout of criticism after
the youtuber tagged an underage streamer
on instagram social media social media
personality is still dealing with the
fallout from his recent grooming
allegations
and had just made his online comeback in
recent weeks
charles
was accused of inappropriate sexual
behavior and in april admitted to
sending flirty texts to minors
um so what he just tagged him but i want
to see the post he just tagged
okay here's the post this is the pose
that's it so he was in a row he's in a
robe what's with the robe though it's
like it's like suggestive it's called
the game that he's playing is some kind
of bedroom game or no he's playing
minecraft
no this wasn't minecraft it was this is
minecraft
okay mom
there's a game that they play it's
called bedroom or something
and it's it's not a sexual game it's
just james is i'm i find the suggestion
the bathrobe and stuff yes it's
definitely so he says about to get glam
featuring real purple playing better
wars that's what it is bed wars it's a
game bed wars is a game
right okay
so
hmm
i think people are just like dude with
everything you've done let's not be
tagging kids right
right and then bake cookies
yeah
let's bless you it's like i'm chasing
after underage boys and now let's make
some cookies
oh there well okay let me ask you about
this photo
this was a recent one with this pants
unzipped this is a recent one
and again this is coming off of
accusations of grooming and sending
flirty texts to minors he literally said
sending flirty text to minors
i don't know how you outlive that you
says i sent flirty text to miners here's
a photo he just dropped a few days ago
of him in an arcade right close to our
kids
kids with and he's sitting there with
his pants on kids
and then he is sippers on is down so
i'm sure that was an accident
so what do you think about this photo
i think
i think he might have a problem
you know i mean i i really thought at
the beginning that
you know he's immature he finds young
men attractive because of him immaturity
he kind of
feels like he relates to a younger
person but if he keeps on getting older
and still focuses on younger kids than
he gets older but the kids stay the same
he's got a problem well yeah there's
going to be a point where something's
going to happen that he will face
consequences for
which he hasn't done yet
there's a difference between like there
there are actors
and people men especially that are
dating women that are half their age
that's you know it happens and guys go
way to go or if they're half the age
right but there are they well like if
you're say if you're in your forties and
you're dating a girl that's only twenty
yeah exactly
he's texting lawrence pewdiepie
right the point is she's legal
she's legal she's an adult she can make
her own decisions if he's
focusing on
um
young boys that are
minor you can't tell me he's not looking
to pick up boys in that arcade no it
that looks like and he's glammed up too
he's looking for some hot ass in that
arcade
why would he take a photo no one's going
to know it's him yeah he's voting
and this outfit is so outrageous and
just the whole thing is like dude after
everything you've been through let's not
go cruising through arcades let's not go
tagging 17 year old minecraft players
just shut the [ __ ] up and lay low and
stop being a pedo sorry i mean pedo
maybe not pedo
do you think that
that was just a photo shoot or do you
think i mean he's not really he's not
really hanging around
you know hey
he could be
why did he go the arcade just went there
for a photo he's out there he's playing
street fighter with a bunch of kids dude
well he's playing you know who he plays
in in uh
yeah
maybe not
well i'm spooked
at the thought that he spooked
spooked
isn't that the word yeah i think you got
it i think you got it
all right that he is attracted to just
underage children i am very smoked about
that myself so i you know the bottom
line is he's he's very immature
but he will get older and if he still
focuses on young boys then he's got a
problem
dad you want to say anything uh spoo you
spooked me gooked
i'm not getting paid for it right
and i'm not going to say anything okay
pay me or shut it or not no it's put up
or shut up pretty much
made all my comments on that he's just
uh
needs to stop what does he have 24
million subs or something like that i
know he's so foolish very popular and
just gonna flush it all down you know
before i even knew anything about him
a while back
i was on youtube and i saw him and he's
so talented i really
you know i don't really wear very much
makeup but i thought well maybe i should
learn and i watch some of his videos and
he's really
he's really very talented and then of
course you find out about this and it's
like
you were sitting really snapped yeah
yeah
well there you go there you heard it
from my parents here the man the kid the
the man has a problem
i think so spooky magoogie yeah it is
all right let's move on do i get a
hundred dollars yes yeah absolutely you
absolutely don't know
there's lunch
okay we're going for lunch all right you
earned it
like you guys are so poor you can't
afford to eat unless i give you 100
bucks damn well it's nice
and we don't even get the money in cash
it's like i gotta put on my credit card
oh god thank you
all right let's move on to advice we
actually have some really good ones here
okay these ones are
some doozies some serious uh
actually really good submissions so
here's the first one this
guy
matched with his therapist
on tinder
wild that's amazing that you can do that
yeah well here so here's the message
okay for context we are both young guys
in our twenties can you wow that's a
really that's a young therapist very
young therapist you missed 29 maybe
smart and
late
ahead he's the only person i've ever
felt so comfortable to be myself around
well he's your therapist right when we
matched he told me he had never met
someone like me and immediately felt a
connection in our sessions didn't want
to acknowledge it in our session since
but we are still talking and sending
pictures he said even if i stopped being
his patient he could lose his job and
possibly even face jail time obviously i
would not want to risk that but how
would they even know is this something i
should let go
or is there something else i could do
it's ironic that i'm the one pushing the
boundaries when he's been helping me
create mine but we both like each other
i feel like he wouldn't keep talking to
me if there wasn't some chance there
that's a doozy
well here's a little research i did find
in preparing to answer this question
well can i give my answer first yeah
okay
it's really not that uncommon
for
for a patient to fall in love with their
therapist
and um
you know when you share all of your
thoughts and secrets and you feel like
you're in a safe zone
and well as they said here he said i've
never felt so comfortable to be myself
around so that's a little bit of a
right of the therapist love trap right
well you know i mean your therapist is
there for you right he wants to guide
you he wants to help you got a
relationship he listens yeah
so um
oh that soda pop anyway uh
so
it's it's not uncommon you know for you
to fall in love with your therapist and
on the other side of the coin
it's really not that uncommon for
therapists to fall in love with patients
because they
are unethical it is unethical i'm just
saying not that they have to act on it
but um
when you have all this time invested
in another person
you're you you you see them on a regular
basis you focus on their needs it's
almost like someone who's a saver
yeah what's what should he do
it's unethical and he shouldn't he
should just
either if he if he thinks that the
therapist is is is helping him
i and he can handle how his feelings are
he can express it
to the therapist although i think the
therapist knows how he feels about him
um according to him he says they're
still chatting and sending photos which
sounds a little flirty
he's saying
it's unethical and he shouldn't go there
he he really he he needs to not go there
it's not because
in my mind if for some reason which it
is unethical and they were to have a
relationship
down the road
with this
with this patient feel like oh is he
flirting with one of his other patients
and it's just it's just a can of worms
it's not ethical you shouldn't go there
there's someone out there that you will
love let the guy help you or if you
don't feel comfortable find yourself
another therapist need a new therapist
cut it out that's what i think get a new
therapist
so here's a little research i found not
in the state of california not only is
it unethical it's actually illegal
for um
oh yeah for there to be any kind of
relationship sexual contact between a
therapist and their client it's always
the responsibility of the therapist to
ensure that sexual contact with a client
whether consensual or not obviously not
consensual is illegal we don't need that
clarified it does not occur
so here's what i think
uh get the [ __ ] away from this guy man
that is so [ __ ] up that he's even
still talking to you
and like you said leading you on to the
point where you say oh there's still a
chance i mean if first of all it's good
that he's not
uh
he's not responding but for him to even
entertain you with this stuff of like
sending pictures sending printers i mean
he matched him on tinder that means he
swiped green on him
i feel like that's already enough
but he said he felt like he said uh
immediately he can be he's manipulating
his feelings maybe he said he's never
god where'd he go he's the only sorry
hold on when we matched he told me he
had never met someone like me and
immediately felt the connection our
sessions
this guy is bad news bro trust me that
is not a good partner for you this guy
is extremely unethical and if he was
dude he would not be saying this stuff
he would not be leading you on this is
very dangerous territory for both of you
and nothing good is going to come out of
this and
you know besides being illegal and
unethical for him i don't trust this guy
at all someone who's willing to
despite his his professional duties
and ethical duties to put you in a
position to make you even think that
there's a chan a romantic chance between
you two it's like highly highly [ __ ]
up it seems like i know for me a large
definitely segment of what your training
is is realizing this is gonna happen to
you
when you're open with people and people
open up to you right so you need to know
you need to expect it and you need to
know how to handle it professionally
right which this guy is not doing at all
well he said that the therapist is in
his twenties so he's young too
i'm regardless he has it doesn't yeah
so i mean first of all like this says
it's the always the therapist is
responsibility remember that it's not
your fault that you're sexually you're
attracted to this guy and you want to
get with him that's that's not that's
fun that happens you know what i mean
it's his responsibility as the
professional to keep these boundaries
clean so if if the fact he should
theoretically be saying we i can't
continue to be your therapist right
right it's it states that he he points
out that it's unethical and that he
could be thrown in jail yes he said that
but he al but it also because he
continues to text him and share yeah
that's that's not that's
that's not cool no because they should
that he
finishes by saying he wouldn't keep
talking to me if there wasn't some
chance there
time to call the medical board i agree
just get out because nobody's going to
do it again this guy this person is in
the wrong career
not good
yeah i if i wouldn't uh i think if he if
he's not going to tell you listen it's
not a pro we shouldn't keep doing this
then then i'm going to suggest that you
remove yourself from this and don't
forget this is this is a one-sided point
of course view we don't really know what
the what the therapist said to him he
did state that it was unethical i don't
understand about the swapping of
pictures though that's uh it's not a
good we don't love it it's not a good
thing we're out get out of there bro
there's good people out there yeah
get the frick out of there okay you know
james charles maybe he could exactly
he's looking
although it's waiting he's too old yeah
he's too old right
sorry if there's a two plus in the front
it's too old for james advice this is
specifically for you mom
um
hey guys
i recently found out that my boyfriend
has been smoking weed
i'm not super against it however i don't
think that i like him doing it what
advice do you have where i won't come
off as controlling or have to give him
an ultimatum
well
she knew he
did she wait she said she i just found
out she just found out okay
i i'd say
this is for me okay excuse me dad
yeah nothing about any of this
well from a woman you know i think she
values your input right you know
i don't have a problem with someone
smoking
um
i think like
at the end of your day
the end of you know
busy i mean some people will have a
drink some people like to smoke
i don't have an issue with it
if she does
then
you know then she needs to possibly look
for somebody else wow
you know i i don't i don't
you know i no seriously i mean if i had
a if
if dad if
dad was someone who drank a lot dad
smokes a lot he does smoke he plays 420
all day every day
no no no i don't yes you do
you can tell the truth here no you know
someone who smokes constantly dad smokes
constantly doesn't he yeah but he's not
working yeah no i'm not i'm not
critiquing you no i was gonna say for
20. with this guy i mean if he's a wakey
bakey that's not good no i
generally
if it's the end of the day never smoke
during most daylight hours like until
after three years sun goes down right
the ball gets lit then time to relax
right but before that right to get
things done
wait what time do you start blazing
you're four a.m a.m
no it's sometimes
yeah exactly me and judge judy you're
going to go home and smoke a bowl
no it's too early what time is it come
on it's two times no it's it's like it's
just something there's 20 that
people will do to relax like have an
after dinner drink and but the thing is
you know
they're just dating it's not like they
have children and she has to worry about
him
well
i no it's not that she should brutal if
she's in love with him right we're
missing some details here then you know
it's a part of who he is and i can i
take a stab at this sure go ahead
i'm gonna make some assumptions here
first of all she says i just found out
my boyfriend's been smoking that
indicates that he's been smoking weed
for a long time and she didn't even know
clearly he's using it responsibly enough
right to where it's not interfering with
his life in a detrimental way so you go
on to say i don't like
him doing it
why don't you like him doing it it seems
to have his [ __ ] together because you
didn't realize that he was smoking
this whole time
unless he didn't smoke a lot when they
first met how long have you been she
said i found out that my boyfriend has
been smoking weight yeah but how long
have they right i'm missing some content
there's a lot there's a lot missing but
what i'm going to tell you
is that
i think she's wrong
personally
because she's saying how do i why do you
why do you want him to stop using you
can't change someone he is who he is and
either you feel comfortable with it and
it's okay
or
you're dating the wrong guy
well what's her issue would she object
if he was having a couple beers when he
came would that bother her also yeah
it's not very specific which is what
advice do you have where i won't come
off as controlling or i'd have to give
him ultimatum there's no advice you are
going to come off as controlling and you
are going to have to give him an
ultimatum so either you're going to have
to accept that this guy smokes weed and
i agree he needs to be using it
responsibly i think he has been if you
haven't noticed until now right and so
you know if he's if he's not if he's
doing a shitty job at work or not taking
care of his [ __ ] at home then obviously
he's got a problem and then and then
that's all different conversation but
you know
if he's just doing something he enjoys
is not not affecting the rest of his
life that's legal and not harming anyone
then then i don't think you you
ha i don't think you need to tell him to
stop doing it yeah
ten years ago when it was still illegal
then you got a whole different story
you're gonna get arrested you're gonna
ruin you know our future blah blah blah
but now it's perfectly legal yeah and
it's just i don't see
where she's coming from she needs to
think about why is this bothering me so
much well you know some people are
straight as an arrow and they feel the
way they feel and it's not going to
change and
if it bothers her that much
just she's dating the wrong guy
to break up with someone i mean look
welcome to the i'm not saying she should
break up with him but she either has to
accept it or move on
we don't have enough information here
but i don't think it's right for you to
ask him to stop
because you don't like it we need more
information here why don't you like it
agreed okay thank you rewrite in again
with more details thank you
come on down
okay finally we've got advice needed
asap with peace and love hi donna gary
and ethan i need some advice for mature
people who are still happily married my
boyfriend seems to only follow half
naked instagram models on social media
and he also likes and comments weird
things on their pictures such as i bet
you smell good
the other thing is he doesn't even
follow me on instagram i feel like i
will never live up to or look like the
photoshopped images of these girls i
think men have forgotten what actual
female bodies look like and it makes me
insecure that he will never be
completely satisfied with me what should
i do about this and how can i feel more
secure in my relationship well
wait can i take oh yeah please because
you're really good at advice so i'll
give you mine first
um
i think
now can she how does she find out what
he's looking at it's all public it is
healthy yeah you can see what they're
like so it's not like she's being sneaky
and and and
i don't think it's sneaky
yeah it's easy to find all right um i
think if he is
interacting
with these women and saying that you
just like you smell good
i think there's a problem yeah i
definitely think they're i bet you smell
good bro you know
[ __ ] that
that doesn't sound like a political
discussion to me yeah the only
legitimate topic no way to twist that
the smell yeah there's no way
yeah i bet you smell like hillary
clinton
i mean this guy's
he's got uh he's some kind of
insecurities or something
because if he's got a beautiful
girlfriend she's real
she's not over the screen i mean i know
some guys that are so addicted to
pornography
that they would rather watch it than you
go you've got a live woman you know
hello
so
anyone you know
no no okay no no no but you know i i i
mean i could say get yourself with some
fancy
you know negligee and you know throw
yourself at him and and but somebody
like that usually has issues it's not
her problem the fix
i think he's got issues he's got major
issues i think so too this guy has got
major [ __ ] issues first of all as
listen i personally don't think
i think even following and liking
instagram models is is disrespectful in
a relationship because
first it's not it's like you can admire
other women's beauty you can look at
pornography and stuff i don't think that
any of that's cheating but it's the
social interaction that's cheating it is
i wouldn't say it's i wouldn't say it's
cheating but it's very inappropriate
telling someone
that you know that's why
that's way far that's
way over the line but like the it's the
social interaction right it's like the
it's the
following it's the investment and then
and then the liking is but the
commenting is way too far i bet you
smell good like i'm sorry bro keep that
[ __ ] to your [ __ ] like that's
embarrassing to her it's disrespectful
and by the way nobody wants to see that
not even the girl you're commenting on
that doesn't help anyone
i think in his head he thinks like maybe
i've got a chance
you know that he's actually dating her
or something i no one's that delusional
you don't think anyone's that delusional
honestly why would he make a comment i
honestly can't even get in his head i'm
assuming he's just
you smell good i don't trying to be
funny or who knows what he's just a
weird comment maybe he does want her to
notice him i don't know i mean i can't
imagine any reason
but but uh the thing is
girl you gotta get your man that will
respect your boundaries and and not make
you feel insecure i understand why you
makes you feel insecure because he's
spending all day you know engaging with
these with these models he's got to make
you feel beautiful and respected and
and wanted right and so he's not doing
that he's making you feel bad and that's
not okay i raised such a good boy
discussion has gone on for years since
the advent of playboy where was oh
you're looking to playboy and these
women don't have realistic bodies and
you're setting your expectations too
high so it's kind of a carryover of that
old discussion of you know what what's
woman's image what should men think of
women and you know it started with the
barbie doll
ew
no really the barbie doll i mean she's
got this like little thing well here
there's two different conversations in
here one is about unrealistic images but
the other is about
interacting with this content
that's the issue the interacting with
the content
is
first of all you got to tell him yo this
makes me uncomfortable you got to stop
if you love him you want to make him
work you just got to be straight up like
this is disrespectful to me i don't feel
wanted i don't feel beautiful i don't
want you doing this anymore and i think
that's a perfectly acceptable
if because if you want to make it work i
don't you that's perfectly acceptable to
put that out there like as an ultimate
i'm like yo you got to stop this [ __ ]
maybe he doesn't even know how it makes
you feel right let's give him the
benefit of the doubt and he shouldn't
mind or object to that right she's just
giving her honest opinion of how i feel
and then leave it up to him either he's
going to continue
or not continue and she can make a
decision exactly i i totally agree he if
he cares about you and he wants to make
it work he's going to be like i'm so
sorry i don't know what's making you
feel that way i'm not gonna do that
anymore and that's a good man right
there who's willing to change for you
but if he's gonna continue doing this
dude you gotta get yourself someone
who's gonna make you feel respected and
beautiful and wanted because this is not
a good relationship [ __ ] that guy cut
him out it's not your responsibility to
make this guy want you more that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] because you you will he
will you will never make him happy
enough maybe he needs to smoke a little
weed and chill out
you know i'd like to chime in on one
particular thing
the comment that she made
that he responded to the girl and said i
bet you smell good
what's the expression a a tiger doesn't
change his stripes
this guy's i think it's leopard in spots
okay leopard spots tigers and stripes
you know what kill him crush him not
kill him don't kill him you honey you
are
you are so worth a better man i'd say
dump his ass right now brutal mom sorry
yeah guys i'm gonna go oh i'm sorry i
didn't you know
watching things like that is one thing
you can't say you smell good
that's that's over the line anyway does
not understand that whether he's got a
girlfriend or not but also like oh you
look good that's gross you smell good
like i'm sorry why do you have to take
it all the way there what if he went
back and told that same woman you look
like you stink to make it up to her
interesting suggestion you look like you
smell bad exactly so i'm making it up to
you honey i'm gonna tell this woman she
looks like she stinks yeah and now we're
good this girl this girl is is so much
worth
more than what she's no you have to
listen my mom's going for the kill i
recommend talking yeah i got to talk it
out now i don't know how long they have
to go no talking all right mom is just
straight to the brutal i'm brutal i'm
gonna have to go wipe out all my
instagram comments
no i'm brutal
so that's that bob that's the show but
my mom has something she wants she wants
to make a plea my mom is a butterfly
keeper and she wants to make a plea to
all of our followers go ahead
the monarch butterfly is in so much
trouble
most of the pollinators are in trouble
like the bees and and
what have you
but uh
you know the game and fishing commission
i mean there's no
safety net for these for these creatures
and um
so far this season i've released 50
monarchs raised and released 50 monarch
butterflies yes the queen it's only cost
me a thousand dollars
it has not you know and um
that it's really tough because
of
the fact that
you know uh there's no habitat for them
and then there's insecticides
and um well they only lay their eggs and
eat a specific plant that grows wild in
the western
united states milk they construct they
just dig it all under yeah and it's good
they don't identify they don't have they
don't know what they're they're digging
up and so it's it's really really tough
so we they can't produce we need more
milkweed we need more milkweed but i
gotta tell you it's a very high
percentage of butterflies that don't
make it out in the wild because they
have so many
predators
it's insane well what can we do about
that will you want us to kill a bunch of
birds no what an animal kill tell them
but let's put it in flies flies are the
words birds what else flies are the
worst
but you know
the thing is if you can plant some
milkweed or at least if you're planting
something and you see identify a
milkweed
and you know maybe right to um
well the state of california just
started a program where they're spending
i believe 10 million dollars oh straight
up
milkweed in the central parts of the
state that's nice yeah yeah
you take credit for that no but
you know well
you know there's a lot of people that
are are you know i'll plant some
milkweed in our backyard
i've been saying that to you
that you should let's do it because
you know the adult butterfly uh monarch
butterfly they need nectar but to
grow a caterpillar from an egg you
absolutely need milkweed because that's
the only thing that they will eat i will
say these one food source animals don't
have a great track record of survival
that is true unfortunately the koalas
are uh
not doing well either it's true they you
know what i'm saying the world is saying
uh uh to the to the butterfly yeah
they're so they're so beautiful yeah
they are they really are plant some
milkweeds you should
[ __ ] monarch who doesn't want to live
we want it to survive more than it does
uh you know what's wrong with like you
know
other plants well and it's other
pollinators too i mean you know without
the bees
we're not going to have fruit yeah we
need the bees you know not just fruits
so many products that bees pollinate
right right right
big trouble there yeah yeah i sent dan
some pictures we're going to put those
in as you're talking about it right then
it's at the top of your dock if you want
to just pull it up oh so you want to see
my mom's grow up yep okay
oh it's just one video dan uh there's a
oh and there's an album right above that
not only that but the changing climate
you know team skeet
that's definitely not the
okay it's not related to the album so
here's my mom's grow operation
this is it's save the uh the bottom
picture shows the bottom picture with
the leaf this is theodore's room that's
been converted that's the office been
converted into full lines but show the
that white dot that is an egg i see
and they're very sticky and you're you
know there's a caterpillar yes that's
the milkweed
and that when the caterpillar is about
uh
two weeks old wait wait wait they they
do that they they make a little silk uh
spot and they hang themselves into a j
they actually look like a j
and then they're like that for two weeks
and then stages to protect them from
other animals so not only do you have to
get the milkweed
you have to get the cages fresh they
don't want to live i'm telling you these
monarchs don't want to live look there's
teddy i i really was a butterfly yeah he
helped me release one of the so here
these are all your butter they are
beautiful see now the thing about a
butterfly that a lot of people don't
know once they come out of the chrysalis
which is like their cocoon they call
them chrysalis
um
their wings are wet and they need to
hang and dry and they're so vulnerable
wasps will kill them because they can't
they can't fly they're just totally
vulnerable
and so i um you know you're the guardian
i try to protect them and i've done i've
had some really good luck you're very
but changing climate has
hard also on them because it gets so
flipping hot
they can't they can't survive here's my
mom
in action
or is there no audio on this
uh there was um
a caterpillar that was turning you know
caterpillars shed their skin four times
while they're growing and at the end
when they turn into a chrysalis
they have to you know they shed their
skin and they wiggle into the chrysalis
and then they stay there for
um a couple of weeks they live about six
weeks and they travel like three
thousand miles to the butterflies yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah
they they they go to um like they'll go
to arizona
they go to mexico the ones from the
midwest there's two different monarchs
yeah what did they do are they mating no
they made they made
no no no they made before in mishwa khan
his cousin owns a
uh hotel down there that that hosts
people who come just to see
millions of butterflies did you show
them the wiggling wait you we missed it
that's just i mean you know did you show
the wiggling we saw the wiggling we've
seen we've seen wiggles
okay i know it'll wiggle a little bit
okay so i'm releasing it out so here's
the big moment
i think it cuts you don't really get to
see me releasing it i have a milkweed
plant that i usually put them on and
then they can fly away when they're
ready
there's your milkweed but i mean you
can't keep them you can't keep plants
they have to be in shade because it's
gotten so hot so the heat kills um oh my
god the wafts killed
yep the air the smog the climate there
used to be like 1.2 million monarchs in
california that doesn't seem like a lot
and and now they're down to like a
thousand yeah they do a count every year
like almost 200 almost like santa
barbara
wait what how is it only two thousand
that means you produce fifty you're
you're actually having a meaningful
impact on the population
yeah but the problem is really i produce
them but then they rep once they they
are are um
[Music]
uh
well they ready
they have to be fertilized they have to
mate with another you know butterfly and
then they can lay eggs again but if you
don't have the milkweed for them to eat
all those bur all those butterflies that
you
saved i mean you have to be prepared
when they come back there's only 2 000
that's crazy well they do an annual
count i believe it's up by santa barbara
as they come down the coast and
someone's just watching shocking how
well they know what time of year it's
just shocking and then when was it there
was 1.5 million how long ago uh two
decades ago roughly because i remember
it was 1.2
million monarchs i remember seeing
monarchs all over the place growing up
this year
1914 were spotted wow that's a big
decline okay let's get those milkweeds
out there people
operation mom yep operation mom of the
monarch
all right i take this very seriously
good
very rewarding
all right guys
that's families
that's it well done oh okay that was
fast so we have um eel is gone this week
this is the last week she's gone
so um
don't panic because we're just taking
our time we're making content you guys
will see don't panic we're making lots
of content we're working
but next week we'll go back to our
regular programming with off the rails
and
families and after dark this week's a
little different
but stay tuned don't panic we'll be back
all right guys thank you so much thank
you smash that like button and smash
that like button
[Music]
so
you